hagamos algunos problemas relacionados
con expresiones variables el primero
dice escribe las siguientes en una forma
más condensada eliminando el signo de
multiplicación eliminando un signo de
multiplicación tenemos para empezar 2
por 11 x si tenemos 11 x y lo vamos a
multiplicar por 2 entonces vamos a tener
22 x una manera de ver esto es si
tenemos 2 x 11 x esto es igual a 2 por
11 que multiplica a x y esto es igual a
22 x si teníamos 11 x y vamos a tener el
doble de eso vamos a terminar con 22 x
siguiente 1.35 por jeff en este caso
vamos a hacer una simplificación directa
para reescribirlos déjame hacerlo con
otro color 1.35
por que ahí tenemos un pequeño punto el
cual podemos eliminar directamente en
álgebra cuando tenemos un número que
antecede una variable quiere decir que
estamos multiplicando ese número por la
variable así es que esto lo podemos
escribir como 1.35 y la hemos condensado
al eliminar el signo de multiplicación
seguimos con tres por un cuarto es una
multiplicación de fracciones directa
entonces la respuesta del 3 a ver veamos
aquí tenemos el 1 aquí tenemos el 2 aquí
tenemos el 3 que es 3 por un cuarto
escribimos el denominador del 3 que es 1
y hacemos la multiplicación 3 por 1 es
igual a 3 1 por 4 es igual a 4 esto es
tres cuartos para el número 3 tenemos
tres cuartos finalmente un cuarto por z
podemos hacer exactamente lo mismo que
hicimos en el número dos es un problema
similar a 1.35 que es lo mismo que 1.35
porque así es que esto de acá abajo lo
podemos escribir
un cuarto
z
o también podemos hacer ese producto
esto sería 1 entre 4 por z entre 1
hacemos el producto 1 por zeta es igual
a z 4 por 1 es igual a 4 así es que esto
es igual a z sobre 4 así es que todos
estos son equivalentes veamos ahora qué
quieren que hagamos evalúa las
siguientes expresiones para a igual a
menos 3 para igual a menos 3 b igual a 2
b igualados se igual a 5 se igual a 5 y
d
y de igual a menos 4 o 4 negativo
podríamos decir en este caso tan solo
tenemos que sustituir cada que nos
encontremos con una a sustituimos menos
3 cada que nos encontremos con una b
sustituimos 2 cuando encontremos una c
sustituimos 5 y cuando encontremos una d
sustituimos menos 4 por limitaciones de
tiempo no voy a hacer todos haré unos
cuantos hagamos entonces el 5 preguntas
5 nos dan dos por a más tres por d bien
esto equivale a dos por a que vale menos
3 2 por menos tres más tres por el valor
de b el valor de b
nos están dando que es 2 esto es
entonces 3 por 2 y esto que es igual 2
por menos 3 2 por menos 3 es igual a
menos 6 déjame usar otro color 2 x menos
3 es igual a menos 6
+ 3 por 2 3 por 2 que es igual a 6 y
esto es igual a 0 no está el orden que
usamos en las operaciones hicimos
primero los productos 2a y 3 b y luego
la suma tenemos que recordar siempre que
la multiplicación y la división tienen
precedencia sobre la suma y la resta
hagamos la pregunta 6 hagamos la
pregunta 6 la voy a hacer por acá 6 es 4
c más de 4 por el valor de c que es 5 4
por 5 más el valor de de de nos están
dando que vale menos 4 menos 44 por 5 es
igual a 20 y más menos 4 es simplemente
menos 420 menos 4 es igual a 16 hagamos
ahora uno no tan fácil
hagámoslo acá abajo esta pregunta 10 la
que se ve un poco más complicada aquí la
tenemos pregunta 10 pregunta 10 nos dan
una fracción en el numerador tenemos a
menos 4 b
si no se ve está muy pequeño pero bueno
tenemos a que es igual a menos 3 menos 4
por el valor de b b que vale 2
así es que esto es menos 4 por 2 hemos
sustituido aquí el valor de a y aquí el
valor de b y como sé que son estos
valores no los están dando acá arriba y
todo eso sobre todo eso sobre 3 c + 2 de
sustituyendo los valores 3 por c el
valor de sé que tenemos es 5 3 por 5 + 2
por de más 2 x menos 4 que es el valor
de de que nos están dando más dos por
menos 4
calculemos el valor de esta expresión
los productos tienen precedencia sobre
la suma y la resta haciendo entonces las
operaciones que nos da en el numerador
tenemos menos 3 menos 4 por 2 - 3 - 8
/ a entre 3 por 5 que es 15 2 por menos
42 por menos cuatro menos 8 15 - 8 15
menos 8 y así el numerador resulta menos
3 menos 8 menos 11
y el denominador 15 menos 87 esto es
menos 11 sobre siete o menos 11 séptimos
y aquí la tenemos este la respuesta de
la pregunta 10 hagamos ahora algunos de
estos aparecen algunos exponentes haré
uno de los difíciles
hagamos este hagamos esta pregunta 18
pregunta 18 en esta pregunta nos dan 2 x
cuadrada menos 3 x 5 x menos 4 bueno no
estuvo tan difícil tan sólo depende de x
hagámoslo por acá arriba tenemos 2 x
cuadrada menos 3 x cuadrada más 5 x
menos 4 y nos dan que x es igual a menos
1 algo que podemos hacer es simplificar
esto antes de sustituir el valor de x
igual a menos 1
así es que cuánto es 2 de algo menos 3
de algo aquí tenemos 2 x cuadrada menos
3 x cuadrada
así es que dos de algo menos tres de
algo nos va a dar menos uno de si algo
así es que estoy aquí es menos 1 x
cuadrada más 5 x menos 4 sustituyendo el
valor de x igual a menos 1 que nos dan
aquí tenemos menos 1 x menos 1 elevado
al cuadrado
5 x menos 1 - 4 y esto que es igual
menos 1 elevado al cuadrado es 1
positivo esto es 1 positivo por menos 1
esto es igual a menos 1 más 5 por menos
1 es menos 5 así es que hay que restarle
menos 5 y menos 4 y esto cuánto es menos
1 menos 56 menos cuatro menos diez esto
es igual a menos 10 y ahora haré estos
dos últimos problemas que son una
muestra del tipo de problemas que nos
encontramos en esta sección de
expresiones variables
el costo semanal se de fabricar x
controles remotos así es que se es costo
y x son controles remotos está dado por
la fórmula el costo es igual a 2 mil más
tres por el número de controles remotos
donde el costo está dado en dólares
inciso a cuál es el costo de producir
mil controles remotos
mil controles remotos el número de
controles remotos es x así es que
aplicando la fórmula voy a inscribirlo
por acá el costo es igual a 2000 el
costo es igual a 2 mil más tres por el
número de controles remotos que en este
caso es x que es el número de controles
remotos que es 1000 y esto va a ser
igual entonces a 2000 más 3 por mil es
3000 al final de cuentas el costo es
cinco mil dólares así es que la
respuesta del inciso a es cinco mil
dólares
ahora inciso b cuál es el costo de
producir dos mil controles remotos bueno
la fórmula la misma costo es igual a 2
mil 2003 por equis que es el 9 controles
remotos que en este caso es dos mil dos
mil controles remotos y esto es igual a
dos mil más tres por dos mil es seis mil
dándonos un total un costo total de ocho
mil
muy bien ahora hagamos el problema 22 el
volumen de una caja sin tapa está dado
por la fórmula b es igual a 4x por 10
menos x al cuadrado donde x es una
longitud en pulgadas y b es el volumen
en pulgadas cúbicas cuál es el volumen
cuando x es igual a 2 inciso a cuál es
el volumen cuando x es igual a 2 bueno
donde tengamos x sustituidos el valor de
2 el volumen es entonces 4 por 2 que
multiplica a 10 menos 2 10 menos 2
elevado al cuadrado esto es igual a 4
por 2 es igual a 8 4 por 2 es igual a 8
y 10 menos 2 es igual a 8 elevado al
cuadrado y esto es es lo mismo que 8 al
cubo esto es igual a 8 por 8 al cuadrado
que es 64 y esto cuánto nos va a dar
esto es igual a 64 por 8 8 por 4 32
llevamos 3
por 6 8 por 6 48 y 3 es 51 51 512 el
volumen de extinción es 512 pulgadas
cúbicas ahora cuál es el volumen cuando
x es igual a 3 luego hacer aquí en rosa
inciso b cuando x es igual a 3 el
volumen es 4 por 3 x es igual a 3 ahora
por 10 menos
al cuadrado 4 por 3 es igual a 12 por 10
menos 37 al cuadrado esto es igual a 12
por 49 vamos a hacer el producto aquí
abajo
esto es 49 por 12 es igual dos por 9 18
llevamos 12 por 48 y 19 ponemos aquí 101
por 9 es igual a 9 una por 434 hacemos
la suma y tenemos que es 8 9 9 18
llevamos una 1 y 4 son 5 el volumen es